mais on va parler de Laetitia Hallyday
parce que là
j'ai dans les mains trois feuilles de
scandale toutes les personnes ici là et
vous devant la télé vous ne pourrez plus
aimer Laeticia Hallyday après pourquoi
mais avant n'importe quoi je l'adore le
15 juin 2022 Laetitia et l'Agence
Internationale de production
d'exposition annonce l'arrivée au moins
de décembre d'un projet exceptionnel
inédit Johnny Hallyday l'exposition là
ça sera d'abord en Belgique puis en
France alors elle expose plein de choses
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose mais
c'est un peu suffit d'avant mais on vous
l'achète pas c'est gratos on l'expose on
vous le rend après c'est pire
qu'ensemble et pour tout ça c'est 350
balles regardez le magret cap et on en
parle on a pas
vous avez tout compris
[Applaudissements]
j'ai très bien résumé alors je vous
donne les prix avant de vous énerver
billet d'entrer ça 22,50 € et si ça va
jusqu'à 350 € comme quand on va voir
Céline Dion pour les packs alors le pack
or je vous dis ce qui est c'est un
ticket d'exposition
un top bag exclusif un mug une affiche
officielle de l'expo waouh attention à
350 euros qu'est-ce que vous avez un
ticket pour l'exposition que tu gardes
un mug exclusif une à mes non mais
vraiment ancienne nous regarde allô il
nous reste des neurones une affiche
officielle de l'exposition une place de
parking waouh un BAT collector non pas
plus tu déconnes
un but en 2D de d'exclusive de Johnny en
plâtre ah je me trouvais mal et
attention une statue en 3D exclusive de
Johnny tout ça
hein
franchement dites-moi la parce que là
j'ai moi je n'ai plus de mots alors
je vais faire comme Siri toi tu dégages
tu dis Florian ouais alors effectivement
le le prix est élevé mais il y a pas que
ça en fait les fans de Johnny ils sont
particulièrement remontés pour un truc
très simple c'est que déjà ça se passe
en Belgique
ça vient en France dans un an il est
belge
les ouais il est belge
il est français
tu peux continuer mes premiers arguments
je reconnais pas nul juste les terreaux
nul à chier
les co-producteurs sont belges et elle
elle dit que c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
installés en Belgique au départ d'accord
en plus Johnny était belge voilà il faut
savoir que Laetitia elle est prise à la
gorge au niveau de au niveau de ses
dettes elle a 30 millions de dettes
fiscales dont la vérité 24 millions et
elle avait alors c'est public qui fait
ça une qui faisait ça une cette semaine
dessus et elle a 13 millions qu'il
fallait qu'elle règle cet été elle a eu
un délai jusqu'au 15 octobre à peu près
pour les régler si elle ne les règle pas
elle va être obligée de vendre aux
enchères la maison de marnes-la-coquée a
fait le mais elle est pas déjà en vente
et donc si elle ne rembourse pas cette
dette dissimi octobre la maison de
Marnes-la-Coquette va être vendue aux
anges et donc elle essaie de s'en sortir
et juste une dernière chose faut savoir
qu'elle touche à peu près 25 % des
royalties qui tombent chaque année sur
les disques de Johnny et aussi sur
beaucoup d'autres produits dont l'expo
etc sauf que les impôts viennent à la
source pas normal
oui sauf que les arguments c'est elle
doit de la thune mais elle a que rien
donc les vaches
alors pas toujours en même temps je vais
prendre un pas choqué bah tiens j'en ai
mis une fois de plus c'est le le bashing
Laetitia quelle phase c'est à dire
qu'elle est émue à l'enterrement de son
mari c'est du cinéma elle l'enterre à
Saint-Bart elle l'enterre trop loin elle
vend Marne à coquette c'est un scandale
il faut pas qu'il faut pas vendre les
joyaux de la couronne dès qu'elle fait
quelque chose c'est un scandale
excuse-moi elle doit de l'argent elle
essaie de s'en sortir elle essaie
d'avoir un peu d'argent elle fait une
expédition
elle vend des petites brologues
aufa du lit qui les exposent
gratuitement c'est faux elle a acheté
plein d'objets au final
j'ai enquêté elle a racheté plein de
Johan elle fait une expédition plus 2000
sur 2000 m² 3000 sur 3000 m² qui a coûté
10 millions d'euros à fabriquer etc il y
aura plein de choses exclusives à voir
les cadeaux excuse-moi pour 350 € c'est
un bus en 3D de Johnny ça se fabrique
pas c'est pas gratuit genre de chose
donc excuse-moi alors Déborah et Lolo
déboraho moi j'ai vraiment été monsieur
et pas depuis mon canapé et je peux te
dire que les objets qu'elle va qui vont
être exposés il y a par exemple des
costumes de scènes de Johnny des
guitares etc ils ont demandé à des
collectionneurs des objets en leur
possession non ce qui ne voulaient pas
venir pourquoi parce qu'ils étaient
obligés de payer le billet d'entrée de
l'expo et qui n'étaient même pas payé
donc qu'est-ce qu'elle doit faire elle
doit faire des répliques de ses objets
là donc ce ne sont même pas les vrais
hommes
Gauthier
et il y a des guitares qui vont être
mais ce seront pas les vrais constituer
le bureau quand tu vas au Louvre c'est
vraiment la Joconde
ultra choquant en fait ce qui est ultra
choquant c'est pas le fait qu'elle ait
envie de se refaire et ça c'est normal
elle a des bêtes fiscales la pauvre elle
est comme ça à la gorge il faut qu'elle
trouve un moyen de elle a pas de métier
à l'idée elle est pas chanteuse elle vit
sur Non mais elle a épousé Johnny
Hallyday elle lui a donné deux petites
filles elle s'est occupée de lui voilà
elle a c'est son ayant droit elle a elle
a tout à fait le droit d'exploiter
l'image de Johnny Hallyday
c'est le prix de l'entrée les gens
d'accord ça
aller au Louvre mais c'est ultra cher
s'amuser qu'est-ce que tu racontes
en même temps et évidemment l'euro il a
raison l'euro c'est l'État qui compense
pour aller voir des répliques de costume
es sans terre cuite je sais pas je suis
désolé c'est pas pour toi un très beau
cendrier Johnny Hallyday alors Isa Isa
t'adore
il y a pas de panneau qu'est-ce que tu
t'es perdu qu'est-ce que tu dis mets un
panneau fais quelque chose
par pas par Laetitia par la façon dont
elle a fait lui donc on va pas refaire
l'histoire et dans la façon dont elle
rentabilise effectivement le fait
qu'elle soit ayant droit en revanche
c'est vrai que ce que Johnny lui a légué
c'est des dettes abyssales il était
condamné à ne jamais s'arrêter de
travailler parce qu'il était clafé de
dette et du coup
elle va vivre du elle va vivre de
l'héritage de Nice c'est clair mais pour
l'instant mais l'exposition en coûte 12
millions d'euros c'est pas de sa poche à
elle c'est sûr elle doit ses 34 millions
d'euros l'État c'est sûr elle a une
deadline pour les rembourser c'est sûr
qu'elle n'y arrivera pas
moins cher que prévu comme ça rapidement
et c'est fini la maison de Los Angel oui
c'est vrai que l'on a racheté une et
c'est vrai qu'elle a un train de vie
alors acheter une baraque elle a de
l'argent pour acheter une baraque mais
par contre elle fout les cendriers de
Johnny pour faire baiser Lolo mais moi
je suis d'accord avec Jean-Michel je
suis pas choqué d'abord on lui tombe
tout le temps sur la gueule à quelle
raison mais parce que à un moment donné
les jours on aime aimer les gens qu'on
aime ne pas aimer qu'on aime critiquer
exactement à un moment donné tu as envie
de dire ouais enfin bon voilà elle doit
de l'argent aux filles ce qu'on fait pas
pleurer parce que je pense qu'il y a
plein de gens qui nous écoutent et qui
doivent 1500 800 euros qui ont du mal à
payer leur loyer donc 34 millions
d'euros comment dire que c'est un peu
surréaliste et que je pense qu'à ce
niveau-là de dette ça se gère ça
s'organise et ça se discute voilà
maintenant on a des maisons elle arrive
pas à la vendre elle va vendre voilà on
va ni pleurer sur elle ni non foncé on
est d'accord et je pense que plutôt de
l'étaler son mec dans une espèce d'expo
il y aura des répliques tu vends une
maison un peu moins cher un peu à perdre
pour elle les souvenirs
2 secondes pardon un c'est marrant de
voir que les gens gueulent parce que
c'est très cher mais enfin on vient de
nous dire à l'instant que les les
Français sont pas content que ça
commence en Belgique ils attendent que
l'export arrive en France donc tout le
monde doit être d'accord pour aller
payer ses 22 €, ça c'est du Chauvigny et
en fait après Johnny les gros piquets
hein il est né en Belgique il a voulu
descendre les champs en France il va se
faire opérer à saint-barthe opérer un
moment là il est pas l'homme de tous les
mondes un tout petit truc parce que tu
m'as pas laissé l'expliquer tout à
l'heure et c'est très important pourquoi
elle démarre en Belgique cette
exposition c'est parce que le régime
fiscal sur place quand on fait une expo
un spectacle etc n'est pas le même qu'en
France moi j'ai selon mes infos c'est
comme ça que ça s'est décidé c'est pas
parce qu'il est belge d'origine et c'est
pas parce que les coproducteurs sont
belge et alors et alors bah excuse-moi
tu penses d'abord au public de Johnny au
lieu de penser au retomber immédiatement
le Nord il peut pas aller à Bruxelles
c'est oui et celui qui a Marseille c'est
Bordeaux ou du monde
pour aller voir l'expo ouais on sent
quand même que tout ce qu'elle fait
pécunier il y a un moment et la passion
dans tout ça
moi je ne vais pas étaler toute la vie
de mon mari jusqu'au slibard il reste
une maison à vendre qui se vend des
patrons
parce que tous les stars sont pareils
maison vaut 15 il la mette à 48 parce
qu'ils disent il y a machin qui a vécu
dedans mais elle vaut 15 alors tu la
mets au prix du marché au prix du marché
partira tes dettes est-ce que tu fais là
c'est ce qu'on fait quand on perd
quelqu'un dans sa famille hein
allez on passe c'est vrai qu'elle finit
bien les
[Musique]
mais
je vais venir sur Twitter j'aimerais
bien savoir si on est nous trop dur avec
Laetitia
je reviens et que je fais des gros
bisous à les Titi c'est juste le
massacrer sur Twitter je vous le dire
les orphelins respecter les veuves
[Musique]
écoutez je vous dis la vérité si on
passait encore les offs les offres de
TPMP ce qui se dit pendant les pubs
lorsque John Himmer il y a 5 ans à peu
près maintenant et il défend il est ici
il défend pourquoi tu défends tout le
temps Laetitia mais me dit tu es con ou
quoi elle a une baraque à tomber à
Saint-Barth si elle me regarde un jour
elle m'invitera voilà Jean-Michel maire
voilà Jean-Michel ma
est-ce que c'est vrai
c'est une garce sorcière